Loreena is on the line in Arkansas hi
Loreena how are you hi Dave thanks for
taking my call sure I husband and I are
happily retired we have two lifetime
incomes each I'm living very well last
year we sat down and created a budget
and that's been doing really well for us
I've got some medical yet and having
just started listening to your broadcast
about four weeks ago I said yeah that's
our budget and kind of scraped it a
little bit and showed my husband if we
do this this and this we can have all
those medical bills paid off in three
months Wow and he said let's do it
so we'll be debt-free in three months
good for you and I'm calling because we
live in a lovely home that we want to
stay in for the rest of our life and we
have no children to which we would want
to leave that house I was wondering
about the wisdom of a reverse mortgage
so that we could use that money
ourselves well no they're not wise
because the terms of them are punitive
they're about three percent higher on
interest than regular mortgages which is
ridiculous you cannot borrow but between
50 and 60 percent of your value back
against your house and the biggest
problem is is that one in five people
who take out a reverse mortgage 20% of
them go into default and you end up
losing the house so I never recommend
them I think they're a really bad plan
I like the idea of you getting a hold of
that equity and enjoying it
but I think you probably are going to
have to make the choice if you're going
to be wise between the house or the
enjoyment of the equity personally I
would stay in the house and you know you
know save my money and after you get
this debt paid off and do some things
with the cash flow that you have I would
not do that do you have a nest egg other
than the home and the the pensions that
you have coming in oh yeah we have about
2500 in the safe for emergencies only
have about ten or eleven thousand and a
401k I haven't touched okay all right so
you don't have substantial money's there
and what is your home worth at 260 maybe
270 and it is paid for no it's got about
a hundred and seventy thousand left on
it hmm okay well I think it's just you
decide whether you want to live there or
not that's what I would do but no I
would not
you don't have enough equity to do a
reverse mortgage to amount anything you
might get a little bit out of it but
you're going to put what you have in
danger when you do that and the fees and
the interest rates are just ridiculous
they're really really a bad idea so I
never recommend reverse mortgages I want
you to get you out of debt instead of
into debt as a way to stabilize your
retirement in your case and other folks
case as a way to build wealth and
stabilize their retirement so I'm sorry
but I'm gonna tell you don't do that
please please don't do that
thanks for the call guys there are some
financial products that are out there
that are bad financial products they're
just bad they're not good for you they
make the company money and they don't
make you money whole life life insurance
car leases credit cards the benefits do
not exceed the risks and the payment and
the fees that you pay out and reverse
mortgages are one of those gold coins
Bitcoin so I mean if you're watching
cable news and between the Snuggie
commercial and the walk-in bathtub
you see an old actor advertising
something that is a financial thing that
means stay away from it and then you can
just name them they're right down the
list they're gold coins reverse
mortgages I mean we've got Tom Selleck
or Henry Winkler pushing those thanks
guys
bad idea shouldn't be doing that it's
not a good product they are bad products
the company that Tom Selleck endorses
has had numerous fines levied against
them for false advertisement for
ridiculous the Federal Trade Commission
has been all over them and so that you
know it tells you what's going on I'm
not saying Tom Selleck's a bad guy I
don't know Tom or Henry don't know
either one of them I assume their agent
booked them to do a commercial and they
did the commercial and they thought no
more about it than that but when you do
the math and you know what I know about
those products they're bad products stay
away from them